dude everybody's got a platform now
though everything's like a platform i'm
watching uh
the eco challenge and it's like um
everybody's like you know i'm gonna have
a platform you know
other people have freckles and i have
freckles and
i just don't want any of these any
spotted people to [ __ ] not be able to
speak up for themselves
i'm like what bear grylls is in it he's
the host
of a series it's a 16-16
12 seconds a little more
is that eddie bravo on the left
say goodbye to that spotify deal
[Music]
but they'd go pretty well though there's
no way they didn't edit him in here
yeah that is who made this brian monarch
who's the editor and that is definitely
eddie probably that's it
insane wow man that's weird crazy well i
hope they
i hope they do well i gotta get a
picture of that yeah that is
they're beautiful i hope they do well
so what do they do this is the world's
toughest i have no clue what to be
afraid of
[Music]
we came here to show the world who we
are
to make sure that those people who feel
underrepresented feel that they have a
voice
i am a tough chick and i'm proud of that
i was diagnosed with alzheimer's to do
this race with my dad
is a priceless experience yeah it's like
a big make a wish
at one point they're racing through like
five miles
damn boys of uh of just like
extremely cold water like in the middle
of the night they have trails are
supposed to be able to ride their bike
and the trails got all wet and so they
said to drag their bike for like 17
miles just crazy [ __ ] man
but it's 10 days straight and you rest
if you want to
and it's whoever gets to the finish line
first yeah and what they make how much
they make
100 100 grand 100 grand it's the hardest
race in the world yeah
before 100 grand i don't know it's the
hardest in the world
that one in death valley my boy cam
haynes does begs the difference
okay there's another 50 degrees in your
shoes melt
the race to get to heaven is the only
type of race
maybe or hell depending how you look at
it that's true yeah you know what i'm
going to do
you know i decided to do last night i
couldn't sleep i'm i'm going to ride my
bike from san francisco to l.a
five days oh i think the train dude yep
dude
ari mantis get it on a long board yeah
what wow that's good
that's gay though
[Music]
is